(ripping sound)
- Oh my god.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] We're gonna get waxed today.
- So many men get their
arms waxed due to the fact
that they want arm definition
if they're working out.
And, also it makes them look much nicer
during the summertime.
Short sleeves, tank tops.
It's just a good look.
- Sometimes I do feel self conscious
if I'm wearing a t-shirt and
all of my hair is exposed.
- I have very find blonde hair,
and so I'm curious how subtle
or not subtle the difference would be.
Rock paper scissors shoot.
Snip snip.
You're goin first buddy.
- Oh.
(giggles)
- That was a little warmer than
I thought it would be, but.
- Can I help you?
Is there anything I can do to--
(ripping sound)
- Okay!
(laughs loudly)
And it just keeps going,
it just keeps rollin'!
- You have so much hair!
- And they said I didn't have any hair.
And they said my hair
was invisible and blonde
and it wouldn't be a thing but,
there it is world!
- You're doing his hand?
- I have to.
- Whoa, yeah.
That was, that's the one Mike.
That's the one.
- I'm sweating now.
- I don't know maybe I'll get more
respect at the gym now with all the
other hairless gym rats, I don't know.
I feel really good, I'm
kind of impressed right now
cause I thought my hair
was so blonde and thin
it'd be like a really subtle difference,
but there's definitely some
more muscle definition.
Alright Mike, your turn.
- I'm terrified.
- We're gonna have to go
all the way up your arm.
We can't just leave it at the fork.
Clean it all the way up.
- No, we're doing just the forearms.
- No.
We'll take it slow because,
well you know in small portions
cause your hair grows
in different directions.
- [Mike] Oh my god! Ow!
(ripping sound)
Oh!
Ah ow!
There's so much more hair on my arm.
Oh god.
(screams in pain)
- If you need me to hold him down.
- No!
- For all the viewers at home,
this was my entire arm
versus half of one of Mike's arms.
- Ah.
Oh my god!
My hand looks like an elephant's penis.
Oh moose!
Ow pandas!
Ow!
I'm feelin the burn.
- This is the fun.
- Ow!
(dramatic music)
I'm exhausted.
- I kinda liked it.
but based on the amount of
hair you see on these sheets,
you could have probably guessed that,
maybe before we started.
- What a transformative experience.
I'm a lot more emotionally
attached to this arm.
Having this arm waxed
really made me appreciate
actually having hair on my arm.
And like this feels really,
really comfortable for me.
And, even though some people
might find it weird to
have a hairy arm, I actually prefer it.
- If you elect to do this, kudos to you.
Someone you're in a
committed relationship with
asks you to wax your arm.
You're reaction is?
- Thank you for dating me.
It's been fun.